one now to tie up put a bow on the
midterm elections one of the races that
we're still talking about is the one
that took place in Georgia the reason
we're still talking about it is because
one of the candidates has refused to
concede and that has given rise to an
extended conversation about something
called voter suppression turns out that
turnout in the Georgia 2018 election was
dramatically up over prior midterm years
57% of registered voters turned out that
compares to less than half in 2010 or
2014 and yet despite that the Democrat
in the race Stacey Abrams says that the
election was stolen from her because
votes were suppressed here's part of
what she's saying it was not a free and
fair election it was not fair to the the
thousands who were forced to wait in
long lines is he the legitimate
governor-elect of Georgia he is the
person who won an adequate number of
votes an adequate number of votes other
words more votes than Stacey Abrams got
but she still won't concede and instead
her PAC has filed a lawsuit alleging
that phrase again voter suppression so
what exactly is voter suppression which
a good scene as a lawyer and former
adviser to the bill and Hillary Clinton
family and campaigns and he joins us
today Richard thanks a lot for coming up
so look I'm totally opposed to voter
suppression I'm for democracy and always
have been so I think this is worth
looking at carefully but I'm hung up on
this kind of logic barrier if voter
turnout was higher than it had been in
the previous two elections how did voter
suppression play a role
so you're enough of a scientists know
that correlation does not prove
causality right let me just let me quote
what does that mean well what I mean is
there was higher turnout all over the
country and here are five things that
Republican governors and legislators did
to suppress the vote over the past few
years close polling places purged
eligible voters they barred felons which
was overturned in Florida voter ID was
required which basically all that that
basically cuts against inner city often
minority voters and early voting was
eliminated in states were early voting
typically favored down
so those steps were taken
notwithstanding that Kemp won
congratulations but that doesn't mean
that there was no voter suppression hey
know this but actually it does mean that
because voter suppression is the
surprise I mean is what it sounds like
it's a suppression of votes but Stacey
Abrams got more votes in any Democrat in
ten years in the state of Georgia she
got more votes than Hillary Clinton God
who was running for president in 2016
and so I mean where the votes that were
suppressed I mean she's got a historic
number of votes I don't understand so
maybe there were attempts made but they
didn't work by definition right I mean
you could have better pitching and still
have more home runs right basically we
know that Kemp had tens of thousands of
people declared ineligible and
disproportionally those tended to be but
no one's claiming they weren't
ineligible they didn't match the ID
didn't that their voter registration did
not match the day of voting for him and
that's the law in the state of Georgia
so I'm not sure that wasn't the only
reason again I think there were plenty
of other again there were polling places
that were closed and there were various
steps that were taken look at the
general you at least concede that
African exit polls suggests that African
Americans voted in the same proportion
they had in previous elections in the
state of Georgia so there was no exit
polling did not detect any drop-off in
black voting period and her numbers
again were the highest for any Democrat
in ten years so will you at least
concede that maybe voter suppression if
it existed wasn't very effective no
because in every other state no because
here's why you can laugh black vote was
up right so the fact that it stayed flat
with a black woman at the head of the
ticket tells you something was going on
to actually suppress it yeah when I say
correlation doesn't prove causality the
mere fact that it was flat doesn't mean
that it wouldn't have been higher black
people required to vote for black
cameras not they tend to oh there tend
is that but that's not the law should
have been along is that what you're
saying what do you say
I'm saying we know statistically African
Americans don't like Donald Trump he
actually did like Stacy a actually after
african-american men like Donald Trump
more than they like Mitt Romney that's
that's true well back in 2016 I don't
think that's the case anymore I will say
well we'll find out it's right Richard
great to see you thank you